don't walk they walk in and I walk back
only prolongs and no one ever won $100
sprint and in the big spot okay and I
might fall let's go forward right now
there's two coming up so we're going to
take steps and what I'm going to do is
take an angle and I'm going to just show
you the angle stay where you guys are
from this slide what is in the way of
other and you are in essence only one
better not to do you understand that
that is going to be my goal so as we go
I am sorry to do that you see boom she
is cut me off you see how she's doing
that boom boom
why would you choose to grab mediocre
strengthening the other person is going
to take advantage of that if you miss me
or I can take your blow it's one-on-one
you would grab me better beat me so I'm
gonna tell you about it go just do the
same thing so you can see it one two and
again this is where I places it comes in
right I'm faster than you
I'm gonna get there three he's faster
than me I'm not gonna get there okay
four don't let it run you occupy the
house okay and five and now you've got
it
[Music]
let's hit that go hey common mistakes
I'm making it you we go you can see how
it nothing's changing my line is this
I'm here that was that this was Bob this
is not doing anything for you just turn
I am immediately trying to get da line
there saving the state we go and I stay
with her love got it
he got me know I let go of them
the situation is already changed this
was five I don't have to win this
situation at that first smooth
I gotta stop that for be coordinated
okay so we're going and the first movies
is there I keep the line
laughter go
[Music]
keep clearing the line don't get hung up
with that I'll be this guy and you get
hung up with her first let me see the
manoeuvre please go hey ready go easy
you get it you pack it up you just
created that momentary single-decker it
does not stay like that for forever okay
let's go okay I did not turn to them
today go go here and this dark glow like
that the initial vector did its job
boom boom Papa is done its job so I keep
going whoa I'm out why I didn't touch
her not because I'm trying to do
anything I'm trying to not let her drop
them if I can get there right I'll do it
so we go back oh my she's gonna get me
that's one of my hat comes out but I
don't go like this it's more like
football I'm trying to go faster
[Music]
you enter that I'm going to motivate you
in something we go boom ah you get it
tight I move so the worst move here
clear then one on one but I want to see
you free or don't want to see you going
to be returned because then I'm very far
from birth when I get the vector do you
see how you want to change directions to
see that must be riding out rage where
you can't get that but it should go by
and he's on the vector where I can now
get this because let's look at his top
she's out of the picture try to remember
your pop okay and we go look at this big
why not I'm here so if you don't you
tell me you'll do the trouble if you
don't touch the Stars so one just barely
touch her okay
so I'm heading that way and this is
where your ID skills are covered in my
problem peasant
okay so as I come around I can see where
she went here so if I don't need to
touch her alone as I'm looking for him
if I do need to touch your elbow ground
her
I just clever Hans like sword work and
I'm looking for him your sword head back
this part just moved out of the way next
if I make a mistake and I get too far
away from her so he can now read the
battlefield and he starts to go the
other way you see that you're going to
split them down this is where your Ted
con comes in boom this way you don't
pick him up or they messed up
she starts you see the gap started again
he's too far from her for me to use this
single letter he's gonna adapt so it
happens whatever the case is when
there's room between her and him she can
read the vector and he will counter it
so well going this way you'll see him go
the other way and you're going to split
depending on your footwork UDV 10 on one
direction
you get it but you're looking for him
coming around the other way so even
though I'm dealing with her it's really
good that I'm fighting it there it is
coming this way
okay let's try it I haven't dropped
anyone okay so we going there's that gap
he reassessments evening me Papa take
mom not in the middle of them they take
hot I want you to think of more face the
enemy
okay not GD a deviation is on the Agena
okay there we go let's see him reassess
what it is right
my back see him we go and I take on here
ah boom boom same thing just soared
deflected preventing him from slowing me
down
let's look how we started unified movie
boom ha now it's not so coordinated so I
haven't talked to anyone but I am
definitely better off than when I
started
okay so don't rob them